おはようございます。
今日もおねがいアイプリ、ひみつのアイプリ、そしてアイプリバースの最新情報をお届けします。
まずはおねがいアイプリからのニュースです。
6月6日土曜日より、ゲーム機設置店舗でサンリオキャラクターズとのコラボレーションによる2か月連続プレゼントキャンペーンがスタートしました。
今回のキャンペーンでは、人気キャラクターおりびあとおねがいパティシエール、そしてポムポムプリンのスペシャルアイプリカードが配布されましたが、ご好評につきすでに配布は終了しています。
ただし、小学生以下のかた限定でセーブカードはまだ配布中ですので、ぜひお近くのお店でチェックしてください。
おねがいアイプリ2だんも引き続き大好評稼働中です。
新登場のいのりちゃんのハッピーバースデーコーデのアイプリカードが登場し、ハピハピハッピー☆マイバースデーというおねがいアイプリバージョンの楽曲で遊べます。
また、ぐみちゃんとおりびあちゃんのデュオコーデカードも新たに登場しました。
2人のデュオ曲フレフレベストフレンズも注目のポイントです。
さらにおりびあちゃんのバズリウムコーデカードも登場し、ぐみちゃんとのデュオバージョンでのプレイも楽しめます。
新しいカードやコーデで、ますます遊びの幅が広がっています。
続いて、アイプリバースの最新情報です。
6月10日水曜日まで、おねがい1だんではプリパラの人気ユニット、ガールマゲドンの3人、アロマ、ミカン、ガールルが登場中です。
プリパラの名曲エビバデビル♪エブリデビルやピュアリ☆スマイリーも楽しめます。
さらに、歴代プリティーシリーズの楽曲を選ぶと、歴代キャラクターたちがランダムでメンバーとして登場する特別な演出もあります。
復刻コーデはプリティーコレクションガチャで入手可能ですので、ぜひお試しください。
また、同じく6月10日まで、アイプリバースおねがい1だんのプレミアムライブではバルーンフェスコーデがラインナップされています。
バルーンフェスピンク、バルーンフェスブルー、バルーンフェスグリーンの3色のコーデが登場し、プレミアムライブのガチャを回すとコーデアイテムが当たります。
スタンプを集めるとマイキャラパーツもゲットできるので、ぜひライブを楽しみながら集めてください。
最後に、2026年夏発売予定のおねがいアイプリ公式ファンブックで読者モデルキャンペーンが開催されます。
読者モデルとして選ばれたアイプリは誌面でコーデを紹介されるチャンスです。
アイプリをもっと楽しみたいかたは応募を検討してみてはいかがでしょうか。
今日は大きな新情報がたくさんありました。
おねがいアイプリのコラボキャンペーンや新カード、アイプリバースのプリパラコラボやプレミアムライブのバルーンフェスコーデなど、どれも注目の内容です。
気になるかたは公式サイトやゲーム機設置店で最新情報をチェックしてください。
以上、今日のアイプリニュースでした。